North Korea is an unimaginable country.
There is only one channel on TV.
There is also no internet.
We aren't free to sing, say, wear or think what we want.
North Korea is the only country in the world that executed people...
...for making unauthorized international phone calls.
North Koreans are being terrorized today.
The day I escaped North Korea,...
...we walked across the Gobi Desert, following a compass...
...and when that stopped working, we followed the stars to freedom.
People often ask me, "How can we help North Koreans?"
There are many ways.
One, as you care for yourself, so you can raise awareness about human crisis in North Korea.
Two, help and support North Korean refugees who are trying to escape to freedom.
Three, petition China to stop repatriation.
We have to shed the light on the darkest place in the world.
Fellow delegates, please join me as we make this a global movement to free North Koreans.